the Kurdish rebel reaction to turkeys
onslaught was clear in towns right along
the border today here in act Rockley
they were dealing with the casualty from
one water when a second came in close
this town is right on the border
the Kurdish rebels who have been pounded
and are now striking back are just a few
kilometers away on the Syrian side this
is a government office probably
deliberately targeted the Kurds have
advanced American weapons from the
Alliance that ended with Donald Trump's
dramatic weekend u-turn other mortars
hit this home nearby children were taken
away injured but ok
the shrapnel though from another mortar
hit a baby who didn't make it
the town's police force quickly
evacuated the area on tano's the
municipality told residents to stay
indoors we saw increased security checks
by plainclothes officers they don't
discount the possibility that Kurdish
rebel sympathizers are in the town well
the suggestion at the moment is that it
was the governor's office or at least
the vicinity of his office that was hit
and as a consequence very very quickly
a volley of artillery was fired from
here back over to Syria you could see
the various different targets the plumes
of smoke as those artillery rounds hit
internationally the condemnation of
Turkey's president for his decision to
start all this has grown there is deep
concern for the safety of civilians over
there and a rejection of turkeys idea
that this could become a safe zone where
Syrian refugees could return and the
sight of more Turkish armor and soldiers
pushing into northern Syria will worry
many who see turkeys offensive as an
attempted land grab and yet addressing
Parliament President Erdogan was defiant
and with a threat for the EU that he
could easily follow through on oh-hey
European Union if you attempt to label
our operations as an invasion then it's
simple we will open our borders and send
3.6 million refugees your way once again
it is the civilians here but much more
on the other side who are the victims of
this war with so many fronts and so few
prospects for peace